bonsoir nous sommes lundi 14 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nous inviter mais également
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition
le parti socialiste et ses alliés
s'incline lors de ce second tour des
élections régionales en ile-de-france
valérie pécresse s'impose d'une courte
tête mais avec une avance beaucoup plus
important dans les yvelines à bien
réfléchir avant d'offrir un animal à
noël c'est l'alerté lancée par sos
animaux 78 qui constate après les fêtes
un pic des abandons le refuge est situé
à rocquencourt
nous recevons en invité une des
bénévoles de l'association et enfin
culture nous reviendrons lors de notre
chronique du lundi sur cette opération
développé par l'unesco avec la
participation des collégiens de
voisins-le-bretonneux la paix et le
rapprochement des peuples à travers
l'art et nous commençons cette éviction
par les résultats des élections
régionales après 17 ans de présidence
socialiste l'île de france bascule à
droite valérie pécresse l'emportent
candidate malheureuse en 2010
elle totalise cette fois-ci 43,80 % des
voix contre 40 2,18 pour claude
bartolone le président ps de l'assemblée
nationale qui a décidé de remettre son
mandat à la disposition de son groupe
n'a donc pas réussi à faire la
différence face à son adversaire en
proposant l'union de la gauche entre
dans l'entre-deux tours quant au front
national il régresse en pourcentage et
en termes de voix mais il disposera
malgré tout de 22 élus dans la nouvelle
assemblée qui siègera pour la première
fois ce vendredi
en 2010 la formation de marine le pen
n'avait obtenu aucun poste et dans les
yvelines à présent vous le voyez valérie
pécresse est très largement en tête plus
de 50% des suffrages exprimés malgré
tout le ps résiste notamment grâce aux
scores obtenus sur saint quentin on
je vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
valérie pécresse et claude bartolone
cher francilienne chère france il j'aime
notre région
mais je sais que vous attendez désormais
non pas des déclarations d'amour mais
les preuves d'amour et bien dans les six
prochaines années nous allons tout
donner pour l'île de france et vive la
france
je remercie les uns et les autres
d'avoir su dépasser nos différences pour
parvenir à l'unité
une nouvelle majorité va s'installer au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france en
républicain je lui souhaite bonne chance
car il s'agit avant tout de la réussite
de tous les franciliens et pour les
résultats complets les indices ce sera
dans une dizaine de minutes juste après
ce journal avec une édition spéciale du
7-8 politique présentée par wilfrid est
riche et nous accueillons avec nous en
plateau alexis andré bonsoir à vous et
merci d'être venu vous êtes bénévole au
sein de l'association sos animaux 78
alors à l'approché des fêtes de noël les
boutiques ne sont pas les seuls à seront
appelés à se remplir pour les refuges
animaux c'est aussi une période de
grande activité entre les animaux
laissés en pension dans les périodes de
fêtes où les familles venues chercher un
cadeau pour les enfants les membres du
refuge font leur maximum pour donner une
seconde chance à des chiens délaissé
petite visite hors concours dans les
locaux de l'association sos animaux 78
où s'est rendue williams elle trop vieux
trop encombrant et surtout sans
propriétaire la plupart de ces animaux
at ellis ici dans ce refuge pour chiens
aujourd'hui chamallows a quand même
droit sa promenade grâce à l'aide de
christine l'une des bénévoles qui vient
soutenir les trois membres de
l'association l'intérêt c'était un
plaisir partagé
voilà je fais ça parce que j'adore les
chiens et que les chiens sont contents
de sortir donc on on est tous les deux
qu'on entende d'être ensemble
avec une capacité d'accueil de 50 places
ce refuge quasiment couple et en cette
période alterne entre chiens sans
propriétaire et pensions qui permettent
de financer leurs activités
s'il n'a activité très très heureux or
les pensions
parce que les gens ils peuvent pas nous
vivons dans la famille peuvent pas nés
les chiens avec eux donc on est complet
souvent pour la période de noël est la
période de genre de l'an la pension
représente souvent une alternative à
l'abandon qui augmente après la période
de fête des chiens cadeau qui reviennent
quelques semaines plus tard on est très
très actif au niveau refuge parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui recherchent des
chiens adoptés pour le cadeau de noël et
nous justement on est beaucoup plus
méfiant à cette période de la drs ne
voit pas justement de cadeau de noël un
refuge qui ne pourraient pas fonctionner
sans l'aide des bénévoles qui
s'enchaînent dans les locaux et apporte
toute l'affection dans les animaux ont
besoin alors alexia rendre l approche de
noël il ya un sujet qui vous tient à
coeur donc c'est l'adoption des animaux
on offre souvent des animaux que ce soit
des chiots et des chatons à noël et vous
tenez à mettre en garde les gens contre
ce type de pratique ce type de cadeaux
et tout à fait un animal c'est un être
vivant c'est pas un livre ou une peluche
qu'on va offrir qu'on va mettre de côté
et revenir plus tard mais vraiment
beaucoup plus tard la un animal c'est
vraiment c'est un entretien quotidien ça
demande beaucoup de temps de l'attention
de l'éducation c'est vraiment sur le
long terme pas quelque chose dont on se
débarrasse comme ça alors vous juste
juste après les fêtes de noël a peut
être quelques mois après vous êtes déjà
confrontés à ce problème d'abandon
s'imagine mal comme que les gens se
débarrassent de leurs animaux qui
avaient acheté de trois mois justement
après les avoir offert à fait comment
quand on récupère un chiot c'est
adorable c'est pas trop encombrant au
départ et puis bah ça grandit et quand
s'agrandissent a besoin d'éducation de
cadres ça demande plus de temps ça peut
faire des petites bêtises
donc effectivement son s'imagine que
tout le monde s'attachent à ces animaux
mais quand on a besoin d'aller
travailler tous les jours de partir en
vacances un peu devenir une contrainte
et les gens n'y pensent pas forcément
départ alors vous conseiller plutôt que
de venir forcément refuge pour donner
une seconde chance à ces animaux
pourquoi justement elle est plutôt un
refuge et pas dans une animalerie ou
dans un élevage dans les animaleries et
les élevages et une
mention d'achat on achète un animal on
achète un chien alors que dans le refuge
c'est vraiment une notion de l'adoption
donc on donne une seconde chance un
animal qui a pas eu une vie jusqu'à
présent réussi
et puis effectivement il ya des frais
quand on achète un animal on va payer
une race etc
alors que l'adoption les frais
d'adoption c'est uniquement les frais
vétérinaires stérilisation
l'identification de l'animal donc c'est
vraiment c'est un geste en fait envers
la protection est arrosé à combien temps
de prendre un chien dans votre refus
alors l'adoption c'est pour les mâles
ses 170 euros et 200 euros pour les
femelles et ça comprend stérilisation
identification et les premiers vaccins
bien sûr alors justement parfois on se
dit qu'il faut faire très attention a
parfois la race de l'animal si on
invente des enfants ou si on préfère
vivre en dehors avoir des activités
physiques
est ce que dans le refuge on trouve
vraiment toutes les truites petit peu de
chiens tous les âges également alors on
trouve effectivement tous les âges
on trouve moi justement y à peine
personnes qui me disent je ne veux pas
adoptés dans un refuge puisque je veux
un chiot ou un chien de race mais
justement on trouve de tout il y avait
uniquement les les chiens croisés ou
âgées qui sont abandonnés il ya vraiment
tous les chiens et l'idée c'est de leur
donner une seconde chance quel que soit
leur âge ce qu'ils ont vécu et leur
personnalité aussi comment vous
travaillez justement avec ces animaux au
sein d'associations votre rôle de
bénévole
alors les bénévoles en a en priorité en
laissant les promène depuis qu'ils ont
pas forcément l'occasion de sortir se
dégourdir et il ya aussi une idée de
sociabilisation de l'animal c'est à dire
qu'un atteint son adoption en le sort on
ne fait croiser d'autres chiens des gens
on lui donne aussi un cadre il peut
manquer d'éducation où on va lui
apprendre à se tenir en laisse il par
exemple c'est un chien qui a été
abandonnée qui avant n'avait jamais
connu la laisse et vous conseiller
peut-être aux gens qui souhaitent donner
une seconde chance
- ces animaux de venir avec la personne
qui souhaite peut-être l'offrir ou c'est
mieux d'avoir un contact justement alors
c'est obligatoire c'est à dire que les
personnes qui s'occupent d'eux des
adoptions refuge veulent absolument voir
la personne qui va s'occuper de l'animal
peut pas faire un cadeau sans connaître
l'animal voilà c'est le si le risque
justement ces cadeaux surprises qu'on
peut faire on peut pas offrir
comme cadeau surprise vous propose
également au sein du refuge de garder
les animaux en pension pour justement
bavard mais les stades de noël ou même
toute l'année c'est vraiment une très
bonne alternative qu'on peut pas faire
garder justement son animal par un
proche voilà la pension sera pas content
mais c'est aussi une alternative à
l'abandon justement parce que quand on
part en vacances c'est le schéma
classique on va faire garder son animal
dans un refuge
mais quand on a un déplacement
professionnel quand on doit être
hospitalisé malheureusement et qu'on se
retrouve sans proche pour s'occuper de
l'animal on va le mettre en pension
refuge et c'est une vraie alternative à
la main dedans aussi
et justement ça revient pas c'est pas
très excessifs comme prix alors c'est un
truc 14 et 16 euros par jour donc la
nourriture est comprise sauf régime très
particulier de l'animal donc c'est quand
même assez intéressant et si ça peut
éviter de de rendre ce lien qu'on a avec
l'animal c'est quand même une belle
alternative alors je rappelle vraiment à
votre message voilà n'offre pas à
n'importe quel animal à noël préféré
donner plutôt une seconde chance à ces
animaux qui sont un refuge parce que
voilà un animal ce n'est pas un jouet
comme les autres merci beaucoup d'être
venu avec nous en plateau alors je le
rappelle
sos animaux ce sont 18 est situé 34
route de versailles art concours donc si
vous voulez donner une deuxième chance à
ses petits pensionnaires n'hésitez pas à
y aller merci beaucoup et à présent un
mot de sport en football l'équipe
seniors de l'étoile sportive de trappes
coach et pour la première fois par
arnaud mbc a concédé le match nul 1 but
partout sur son terrain au stade de
gilbert son chant sacs contre saint leu
la forêt dans le val d'oise une équipe
qui occupe actuellement la 2e place de
la poule c de promotion d'honneur les
trappistes qui évolue en but en bleu
ciel ce dimanche font du surplace au
classement après 10 journées les saint
quentinois sont cinquièmes de la
division à 14 points du premier l'équipe
de houille la montée s'annonce donc
compliquée pour les trappistes et
culture à présent comme chaque lundi
nous accueillons sephora namani bonsoir
à sephora sauf lorraine alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'une
exposition qui a été présentée en fait l
ex passe de covile mes hommes à un mot
avant le shaq 15 avril c'est la journée
mondiale en fait de l'art en écho en
fait à la date de naissance de léonard
de vinci qui était né le 15 avril 14 152
et donc à cette occasion l'association
internationale pour l'art le comité
nal français des arts plastiques et
l'association internationale des arts
plastiques tous partenaires de l'unesco
organisation des nations unies pour
l'éducation la science et la culture se
sont associés autour d'un projet
ensemble pour l'art ensemble pour la
paix les enfants s'engagent pilotait
parfaite emma binet ouakka artistes arts
plastiques et habitante de
voisins-le-bretonneux un projet qui a
réuni les enfants de différentes écoles
de france et de la région de fès du
maroc ait sadn autour d'un thème celui
de la paix par le biais des arts
plastiques la restitution de leur
exposition commune se faisait donc au
centre de covile samedi et dimanche
derniers les représentants des
différentes associations étaient
présents notamment martine pasquier
secrétaire exécutif de l'aïe ap qui nous
a présenté l'objet de son association
depuis quelques années par contre la ja
happ s'est beaucoup investi dans
l'éducation artistique car elle juge que
pour atteindre les objectifs de l'unesco
qui est de faire régner la paix dans le
monde
il faut d'abord réharmoniser le
psychique de chaque individu et que pour
faire la paix il faut d'abord la sphère
en soit avec soin pour la faire à
l'extérieur de soi et pour information
la ja paix en fête a été fondé dans les
années 60 par les grands de l'art
contemporain tels que georges braque ou
sonia delaunay pour la défense de la
condition de l'artiste
quels sont les écoles qui se sont
engagés sur le projet c'est fort alors
en france vous avez le collège hélène
boucher de voisins bretons n'est ainsi
que son service jeunesse le club des
enfants de l'unesco le collège
paul-verlaine des mureaux et pour le
maroc vous avez deux écoles de la région
du moyen atlas l'école de rast et
bouddha heitz haden et les enfants de
sidi khiar de kandahar alors je précise
bien de la région du moyen-atlas parce
qu'il était vraiment question d'associer
au maroc des écoles un peu plus reculée
dans les montagnes pour permettre un
véritable échange culturel diversifié
c'est cette population-là rural qu'il
faut amener vers la culture
el harrach est justement à ce fléau
contemporain aujourd'hui celui de la
radicalité du radicalisme parce que ces
jeunes qui sont fragilisés dans les
données dans les villages par exemple
ils ont pas beaucoup d'ouverture sur le
monde et même sur eux mêmes d'ailleurs
et sur leur environnement tout à fait
immédiat et non pas de culture donc ils
sont des proies faciles pour tomber dans
les bras de la radicalité là est
vraiment reconnu comme un moyen
d'échanger et de sensibilisation à la
diversité culturelle il nous apprend à
vivre ensemble et à se reconnaître dans
sa différence
donc l'idée était vraiment de faire
réfléchir et inter agir autour du thème
de la paye de la vision d'un monde plus
harmonieux des jeunes de différents
univers par le biais d'un langage commun
celui des arts plastiques
donc ils ont laissé libre cours à leur
imagination en utilisant différents
matériaux pour rendre compte de leur
façon de penser selon l'aïe ap
l'art plastique favorise l'autonomie et
le libre arbitre des jeunes pour en
faire des citoyens investi et à terme
capable de construire un monde en paix
alors donc nous avons de la chance
d'avoir cette exposition à voisins le
bretonneux le week-end dernier quel va
être le devenir de le futur de cette
exposition
donc en fait après ce week end en début
d'année on pourra la retrouver à
l'unesco et puis elle partira au maroc
dans les différents lieux partenaires de
cette exposition donc les lieux de fès
et dans la région d'agadir également
qu'il sera l'année prochaine un futur
partenaire sachant que chaque région du
monde
désireuse de la présenter pour échanger
autour est tout à fait susceptible de la
recevoir et puis fatima binet-ouakka
table de l'exposition forme également
différents voeux autour de ce projet on
les écoute c'est d'accueillir quelques
enfants d outsider ou doubiens deux
roues alors ou bien de céder régnard
bien sûr ici là voisins ou ailleurs -
l'unesco
parce que c'est ça les change c'est
c'est de faire quelque chose qui se
perpétue et ne pas non plus rester à
faire un événement et que ça reste alors
c'est pas mon but ça m'intéresse pas
étant dans le conseil d'administration
du conseil national le but c'est de
faire connaître la culture
et puis travailler aussi sur la paix
parce que la paix elle est essentiel
aujourd'hui pour notre vie et surtout
pour nos enfants ou nos enfants ils ont
besoin d'être emplis d'être animée
d'être voilà d'avoir de l'espoir et nous
finissons donc pour sur ce beau message
merci beaucoup au sephora
c'est la fin à présent de cette édition
merci nous avoir suivis dans quelques
instants le 7-8 politique présentée par
wilfrid et richir viendra spécialement
sur les résultats des élections
régionales vous retrouverez tous les
résultats sportifs de ce week-end dans
le site sport présentée par michael bay
d'euros ce sera demain à 18h30 quand à
moi je vous retrouve demain pour le
journal et vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée
vous